c'est la pénalité du bonus défensif
montigny le bretonneux se contentera de
ce point une défaite 11 à 18 face à
marcoussis lors de la première mi temps
les deux équipes ont commis de nombreux
en avants après 20 minutes de jeu le
score est toujours vierge mais montigny
le bretonneux débloque la situation
après une mêlée le demi d'ouverture tape
un coup de pied par dessus pour lui même
plaquée au sol il réussit à transmettre
l'ailier remet intérieur au numéro 13
pour inscrire le premier essai de la
rencontre après une pénalité convertie
en fin de première période montigny mène
8 0 à la pause on a su rester dans le
match sur la première mi temps on a su
proposer du jeu collectivement ce qu'on
n'a pas réussi à faire sur les matches
précédents et c'est ça qu'on relève
qu'on va relever aujourd'hui et qu'on a
eu la force mentale d'aller chercher le
bonus défensif dans les dernières
minutes
la seconde période a basculé en faveur
de marcoussis revenus des vestiaires
avec un jeu plus direct sans séquences
de passes et des avants dominateurs les
essonniens réussissent à inscrire une
pénalité et trois essais dont celui ci
après une touche et un maul qui
s'écroule dans l'en-but unis montrent un
ensuite on a commencé à subir dans les
impacts
marcoussis a pris le dessus face aux
logiques
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ne fait
pas des génies et il faut pas oublier
que c'est les leaders de la poule et
qu'ils ont des joueurs à des postes clés
qui font la différence c'est qu'ils ont
réussi à remettre la balle
la main sur la balle au classement
marcoussis conserve sa seconde place
montigny le bretonneux pointe au 6e rang
prochain match dimanche 21 janvier face
au troisième de la poule garches
vaucresson
[Musique]